well it looks like dogs are not man's
best friend in the first trailer for
Strays yeah so after Reggie voiced by
Will Ferrell is left to fend for himself
in the city thanks to his owner Doug
thumbs down Doug he meets bug voiced by
Jamie Foxx and a pack of Strays yes and
after learning to adjust to the Stray
life Reggie decides that he wants to go
home and get sweet puppy Vengeance on
Doug okay so Jen and I have not seen
this trailer yet so this is going to be
our genuine reaction you ready I'm ready
let's see it
today is going to be the best day ever I
love sunshine I love butterflies but
more than anything I love done hey
shut the up
that's Doug the best owner in the world
we're playing this game called fetching
he drops me off really far away
and drives home without me when I bring
the ball back he says that's how I know
I won the game
hey honey you ever been with an Afghan
before I don't think so but thank you
thank you for me kid he left your oh
that can't be right you are officially
astray that would mean
duck doesn't love me poor little guy I
should probably talk to him I am a
therapy dog Fred you can learn how
beautiful he can be when you're off the
leash this beer is making me dizzy he's
about to get real Dizzy up in this I'm
having a great time
right here
just to get Violet
dang you I'm going back to Doug's what
man he needs to pay for what he did with
the only thing he truly loves I'm gonna
bite his off oh wait did he just
say yeah I'm still a little drunk but I
said I'm gonna bite his oh we go
even under these strange circumstances
completely lost and my little puppy paw
pads are really hurting right now so how
exactly could this get worse
all right
thank you
guys we've got it to rip off
what are those kind of looks like food
oh
give me a second you look different you
look different too how so is it my human
hands
okay we were dying the whole time see
that coming out no I had to look it up
while the trailer was going so this is
rated R makes sense you know when they
say like kind of in the same vein as Ted
yes uh so this is produced by uh Chris
Miller Phil Lord definitely the mines
behind like 21 Jump Street Lego Movie so
this is very very funny do you remember
Homeward Bound yes no you don't no I
don't know I'm 10 years older than him
so anyway it's basically an iconic movie
from my childhood where the dogs talk
and like uh Michael J fox was one of the
voices so this is pretty cool that you
have such big actors voicing dogs it
looks so funny I can't wait to see it
you it looks hilarious um I did not
expect that at all no I thought it was
going to be like life of pets Vibes yeah
like kind of cute yeah kind of cute but
then it went like Ted Vibes and I was a
whoa but wolf Will Ferrell hilarious
perfect for this yeah it's perfect for
this yeah I Love Will Forte as doug
because like you want to hate Doug and
you do so I just think it's very funny
the humor is funny the fact that these
dogs are eating mushrooms and there's
going to be a whole scene where dogs are
high off mushrooms and it's so funny I'm
here for it